more about the debt ceiling now joining
us at the table Joseph Gallo senior
fellow at the Peterson Institute for
International Economics we are also
joined by Veronique de Roos a of the
George Mason University she has senior
fellow at the Mercatus Center let's
begin with estragon young debt ceiling
the immediate fiscal and economic
implications of of today which you know
is a big day tons of headlines here
reaching the debt limit what does it all
mean to you well it actually I don't
think it's a big deal today but it's
emblematic of a big problem and
something we're gonna have to deal with
there were telling months but the
Treasury has Secretary of Treasury
Geithner has said that it was quite a
few things he could do to postpone any
problems today and I think in fact he'd
actually do quite a bit more than he
said he could do so he get into the fall
maybe the end of the year but it's a
problem has to be dealt with at some
point what is the most important thing
he's doing or at least something that
that we can understand to the non
economist sitting at the center of the
state of hall and at home explain to us
well I guess there's the the short-run
issue is just how Treasury can economize
on cash though doesn't have to borrow
will be able to borrow going forward but
it has lots of assets that it can move
around to avoid running into that
ceiling but I think obviously the bigger
problem is is the budget you know how
are we going to deal with our budget
deficits point forward
and that is much more difficult problem
to our second gasp Veronique de rouget
of the George Mason University what do
you suspect other countries around the
world are seeing as they view the
situation here than us what's a
perspective countries and their
leadership have a short-term memory us
or whether they actually follow you know
what's happen or or inform themselves
about and about what's happening in the
past but we've been down that road
before right and in fact you know
markets don't seem investors don't seem
to be particularly worried and that's
because I mean there is an understanding
that there is actually a lot way more
than secretary Geithner's get nerd
claims he can do that he can do to
actually not get us in a really bad
situation and there's also probably the
understanding that Congress will you
know also try to avoid us getting
completely in the world the more
important question and I will agree with
your guest is the fact that you know the
budget and what we're going to do for
the longer run is what is really key the
debt ceiling is nothing except you know
like a leverage used phone numbers on
the bottom of the screen for our gas as
we continue to look at the debt ceiling
the u.s. reaches its debt ceiling today
and i think august second was a date
that the Treasury secretary put out
there as a drop-dead date what does a
drop-dead date exactly mean i don't
think it means anything especially
considering that again secretary
Geithner has already changed that debt
that day date four times I mean like he
said we're going to default for sure if
we don't raise the debt ceiling by the
first the end of the first quarter of
the year and then it was May and then it
was July and then it was August which
shows that you know maybe when he says
he we can't he means like you know it's
just not his favorite choice i it isn't
but the worst-case scenario is a
supposedly default I there's no way
would get there and joke and Yannick
explained for us help us understand what
default means what legal obligations are
all about in this area sure a default
would be if interest payments or
principal came due on some Treasury
instrument and the Treasury was not able
to pay the owners cash that would be
unthinkable Geithner said that's
unthinkable and i believe it is
unthinkable and frankly he if he raised
this as a concern but he actually is not
saying he will default I think what what
if you actually I think what would
happen in a worst-case scenario would be
a partial government shutdown please
thank you I mean I totally agree is like
what needs to happen is that we pay
interest on our debt we have way more we
have way enough tax revenue coming with
the government collects revenue on a
daily monthly yearly basis and we have
way more to pay the 200 billion dollars
over even if it's really hundred billion
depending on what the interest rate it
to actually never have to really default
on our debt and that is a key message to
send the American people one of the many
headlines out there today papers full of
headlines on the debt ceiling Financial
Times Treasury urging action letters are
coming from Treasury over to Congress to
get a move on on this thing and we have
two guests in our studio to help us
understand the debt ceiling a bit better
they are Veronique de rachet of the
George Mason University she is senior
fellow at the Mercatus Center also Joe
Gallo senior fellow at the Peterson
Institute for International Economics
lots of calls coming in let's start off
with Marty on the Republican line from
Pennsylvania good morning Marty well
good morning Paul and thank you c-span
good morning guests you know I've been
holding for about 20 minutes now
listening to the show and the point was
just made as I was about to come on that
as far as the debt ceiling is concerned
and the servicing of that debt and all
the chatter we're hearing 24-7 about the
fault I just don't get it at all
if our receipts money coming in that is
is about 2.2 trillion and point two
trillion or two hundred billion has to
go to service our debt why are we
talking about it the fault is it just is
it just a certain prioritization is
being picked to politicize in other
words couldn't we just as easily quote
default unquote on social security or
education has been oh why is everyone
talking about the fault on our debt when
we're getting 200 billion or just for
service but we're bringing in two
trillion I just don't understand while
the chatter about the fault can you put
it in maybe and maybe even simpler terms
sure let's hear from our guests so it's
a very good question the short answer is
probably politics and also kind of
trying to get leverage and things going
on the part of secretary Geithner that
being said I mean the issue with the
debt ceiling is it completely bipartisan
one each time a party's in is in office
and is about to hit the debt ceiling
they're very very very fast to raise the
default threat I mean Reagan did it so
it's like what he's doing for expediency
reason I mean everyone has done it but
you're you're right it's like as long as
we be interested in the principle that
is coming do we are not going to default
to which secretary Geithner says that no
actually any default any non payment on
our obligations would be would be the
equivalent of default I do not agree and
I think I'm not you know I'm not a
majority first we have lots of reserves
lots of assets that we can actually use
to so we don't come to this but I
suspect the American people understand
that there is a difference between
you're telling you know you're you're
you know someone that you're not going
to pay them and like take telling a bank
or your credit card company or you're
you're you're the person was lending you
money for a loan that you're not going
to pay them
I guess I agree with Vernick totally I
would just say that defaults would be
the worst thing we could do it'll be
catastrophic and I think everyone agrees
people raised that word to scare people
so that we can reach an agreement so we
can seem to come to the brink and then
you know reach an agreement at the last
minute but there's no chance of the US
government will default as vernix said
there are plenty of assets there's four
hundred billion dollars worth of gold
there's two hundred billion dollars
worth of mortgage-backed securities
there's a bunch of other assets that
will be harder sell but this would this
would all be done first then the next
thing would be to shut down the
government at least partially New
Bedford Connecticut Abraham thank you
for waiting good morning good model yes
sir independent and I think that
Republicans or Democrats that put in
there for our welfare but for the look
of things it like they're playing
politics with our life with our economy
and everything I am of the view that we
should help that politics and went to
the benefit of the people who put them
there they should stop the bickering and
go ahead and look at what is happening
the citizens everybody is suffering a
chronically but they are they're being
paid by me the taxpayer so my point is
that they should come to an agreement
work together we put them there to web
together not be fighting on ratification
ironic to Russia how long will it take
to get to that point I don't know I mean
this is I mean you make a very good
point and I'm with you this is what I
want but I don't the nature of politics
right is winning the next election
whether you're Republican a Republican
or a Democrat and and that means looking
good at all time even if it's not
necessarily good for the country for
taxpayers for Americans and for citizens
and so unfortunately I mean all these
bickering is a product of this all the
bad laws all the bad policy that we're
getting are the product of politics and
serving interest groups before serving
Joe can yell to the gold issue that you
brought up it is one of the stories out
there too
it's the off lead in the Washington Post
and elsewhere a golden solution to the
debt problem mostly they're saying is
coming from conservative economist sell
the gold what are the implications there
well secretary Geithner does not want to
do this and it would send a bad signal
and and as Vernick mentioned to me
earlier just before obviously a large
sale in a hurry might push down the
price now one solution to that would be
you know if the government wanted to buy
a little time the Federal Reserve might
agree to buy that gold and then in the
eye and the idea that it might sell it
back when the problem is solved but
these are all just stopgap measures this
is not this there's only at current
prices four hundred billion dollars
worth of gold which is only about a
quarter of our budget deficit so it's
it's not even you know it doesn't get
the kisses three months yeah and also
mean that yeah because the US is the
biggest holder owner of gold the O's I
think something like twenty percent of
the reserves as soon as the yesterday
its goal in the price so it's not even
going to be four hundred billion and
more importantly I think I mean the real
solution to our problem is to address
our a long time I mean we haven't had a
budget we're on our way to not having
had a budget for two years and we're on
our way to see the biggest explosion in
spending in the history of our country
and and without unlike you know the
second world war without chance of it
going down and this is what needs to
happen to ocala florida now where George
is calling on a Republican line we're
talking about the u.s. debt ceiling go
ahead George yes good morning everyone
tonight one suggestion for c-span maybe
you should give the guests all a pad and
a pencil because so many times they
evade the question by saying that you
put a lot on the table and I you know
it's the person has two questions anyway
they they both have pads and pencils
here though we'll just let you know and
well maybe instrument go ahead anyhow my
here's what i like to say my first
comment is I think the political and
social divide in this country is now
between the gimmies and the getters
twenty percent are paying eighty percent
of the tax and and I'm a victim
a progressive taxation being a sub S
corp I get killed forty-seven percent of
the working people pay nothing they get
the full return and people are calling
in and telling everyone that they are
justified in taking others hard-earned
dollars I've never heard such a thing I
mean where is humility but it just seems
to me that it's a tough sell trying
attempting to to tell the successful to
hand you their hard-earned dollars i
mean as they attempt to do this but my
big question is this could anyone please
now the debt if forty seven percent of
the people were paying taxes maybe we
would have a chance at it except that
the more you everyone pays the more the
democrats spend so I'd like to ask this
question if you could justify where is
it written I'm here in Florida the
excesses and entitlements is amazing the
cruise lines the French food franchises
are full the casino it's nuts they've
got 500 hours worth of betting clamps in
these communities that don't allow
anyone under 50 on every corner they're
not even growing a tomato but I could go
on and what I'm not please where is it
written in the Magna Carta the Ten
Commandments the Constitution that I
should give my money which should be
slated for my next generation my son to
some other people George thanks that's
it from our guest so first I'd like to
say that I agree I think everyone should
be paying some taxes just as a incentive
mechanism that being said the reason why
forty seven percent of tax units do not
pay the income tax it's not all Texas
the income taxes because Congress and
most of them are very poor people I mean
there are a few millionaires but really
I mean it's mostly very poor people is
because Congress distributes social
benefits through the tax codes and and
we can debate whether it's a good thing
or a bad thing well I would like to say
that I don't know anyone in this country
doesn't pay taxes i mean everyone buys
stuff at stores or sales tax everyone
buys gasoline there's gasoline tax
everyone who
workspace oh security tax no matter how
little they earn so everyone pays taxes
I think it's only fair that those who
make more should pay more and I don't
have a problem with that movie not good
go ahead i just think it's it's a
society's compact with itself those who
do better pay more we will stay with our
guests for about 35 more minutes or so
and Nashville Tennessee is up now
independent name's Sean go ahead Sean
yeah I have fun with the study Sean you
still there he had a lot to say and we
dropped off try to call back Sean will
get you in as we know you had a lot to
say we'll get to Donna now on the
Republican line from gyorko Pennsylvania
are you there Donna Donna you there no
Donna let's try to pika Kansas kevin is
a calling from Topeka are either Kevin
yes I am go ahead sir you're on the
Democrats line good morning good morning
I like to know I like to know how come I
never heard about this during the Bush
administration eight years of
destruction and not one word about
denying the death still and I just can't
understand that so could you give me an
answer on that why all the sudden now
when Obama administration is in office
we hear about problems with the deaf
still in the anyway Shogun yo can you
give us some perspective on it I think
actually it did come up and Veronica
actually may know this better let her
answer yeah I mean there's been there's
each time there is there's there's an
issue is raising the debt ceiling the
party you is in the majority is in favor
of raising it and the parties in the
minority is against raising it like in
2002 to President Obama who was then a
senator voted against raising the debt
ceiling so it is it is it's always been
a very partisan issue over and over
again and it's been the debt ceiling has
been raised ten times in the last ten
years so there's been a lot of talking
about the debt ceiling as we tie this
issue of course to spending and budgets
and that kind of thing there's a story
one of the many
again it's in the New York Times here
about an idea that's been out there
automatic cuts to curb deficit something
that's been put out there Jackie comms
writes that the while talks continue
here's here's one idea that they're
nearly all congressional Republicans
want caps only on government spending
back by the threat of across-the-board
cuts if agreed upon targets are exceeded
mr. Obama most Democrats and several
bipartisan Budget groups one annual caps
on deficits with both spending cuts and
tax increases triggered if the caps are
breached wanted to get your take on this
idea of triggering action when some of
the goals aren't Beach because the
article points out that if the folks
back here can't get it done something
automatic should be put in place joking
yeoman yeah I would agree with that I
think one area that I feel strongly and
maybe of our Nick will disagree is I
think it should include both spending
cuts and tax increases because I think
there's no way we're going to solve this
problem entirely on spending cuts given
the tremendous increase in aging of the
population it's that's raising spending
requirements for retirement and health
care so at some point we're going to
have to have more tax revenue spending
cuts and tax increases that's the
Democratic you know you want to simplify
the base and get rid of all the
deductions that are granted to actually
a lot of very wealthy people and with
you i mean i'd like to see serious
reduction in rates i mean basically have
fundamental tax reform and in this way
this is a way to put revenue on the
table but spending cuts spending is
really what put us in this situation
whether it's war spending on education
even spending on lots of things that we
like but we've done it in a way that's
been very unreasonable and obviously
pilot o pilot type program like social
security medicare medicaid are a big
problem because they have been they've
been increased the eligibility has been
increased the the promises have been has
been increased without ever really
considering who was going to spend and
to pay for all this money and it is time
we have this actual honest debate it's
like we want we want all people to be
fine seniors to be to get money fine but
we have to realize who and how is going
to pay for it it's going to be the
younger generation and that has real
consequences from the practical to the
political more the headlines here
Baltimore Sun debt-limit litmus tests
they write that the Tea Party groups are
pressuring lawmakers to take a tough
stand that's in today's Baltimore Sun
the christian science monitor has this
headline this morning tea party versus
big biz shot of dick armey here of
freedomworks and matt kibbe they're
usually natural allies the Tea Party and
the business lobby are at odds over if
and how to raise the national debt
ceiling that's in the christian science
monitor and paul krugman rights in the
new york times this morning about what
he sees as america being held hostage
what has changed he asks the answer is
the radicalization of the Republican
Party normally a party controlling
neither the White House nor the Senate
would acknowledge that it isn't in a
position to impose its agenda on the
nation but the modern GOP doesn't
believe in following normal rules so
what will happen if the ceiling isn't
raised it has become fashionable on the
right to assert that it would be no big
deal Saturday the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal ridiculed those
worried about the consequences of
hitting the ceiling as the Armageddon
lobby it's hard to know whether the what
us worried types believe in what they're
saying or whether they're just taking
out a bargaining position but in any
case they're almost surely wrong
seriously bad consequences will follow
if the debt ceiling isn't raised any
reaction I just want to say like I've
spent a lot of time my research the last
six or two years actually really looking
at the literature on the implication of
debt on our economy the implication of
like the reaction of investors to to
spinning and two and two big deficits
and debt and I think there's a pretty
big consensus and there's been that
there is a level where actually debt and
deficits develop symptoms of their own
and it hurts our economy and more
importantly there's a very good people
that just came out called a decade of
dead bye-bye
ken rogoff and carmen reinhart who are
very respected economists and what they
talk about is the impact on interest
rates of having sustained level of debt
and they say is its increased that that
spooks out investors and and then
increased interest rate not not being
able to Bora Bora Bora Bora Joe vijnana
a perspective there yeah I would say
totally agree with everything Vernick
said about jet ultimately is very costly
but I do think there's a there's a
question as to whether our taxes too
high or spending too high I think it's
not clear to me that that the position
that you cannot raise taxes at all is
doesn't make sense to me but I do I
would rather do it by broadening the tax
code exactly not raising rates so much
as closing loopholes now I forgot the
point I want to make so we'll bring it
up we'll just move on to a call if you
bring it back we'll be glad to hear from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Republican Harry
you're on the on the line now thanks for
waiting yeah good morning I got a quick
statement a little story and like that
little bit time not a lot k my son moved
to Georgia when he was 20 made Devin
dollars and I already shared an
apartment with two others I was future
wife moved down here on the same time
with the daughter she was an unmarried
mother so both of them started low
paying jobs they both took college
courses now they're making a comfortable
living I don't know what they're making
probably run two hundred eighty thousand
a year 22 of them they paid 770,000
dollars in taxes last year and the first
thing they did with the stimulus
packages they gave welfare recipients
eighty dollars a month extra for food
steps they're packed taxes paid for 800
people to get eighty dollars a month
extra why is it fair to people in that
income tax range have to pay for
everybody else number 1 number 2 i'm 64
the time I've been working Social
Security and Medicare I put two hundred
and seventy thousand dollars in between
me and a company they want to cut the
Social Security give me my 275 of
tax-free you don't have to give me so
security
I mean this whole thing's getting
ridiculous with this debt they keep
giving away money to people don't work
and are not productive and then they
want to say let's get the rich people
thanks let's start with Joe gallo well
I'm afraid I have to say I don't agree
with our caller the system is set up to
benefit everyone and some people are
able to do quite well and you know we
have government that enforces laws and
rules contracts you have police that
protect you a fireman to protect you
defense etc and it seems to me only fair
that those who make more should pay more
I think that's a fundamental principle I
would believe in chronic do regime I
would say actually that you know the
good news for for our caller is like it
is the case actually the income tax is
extremely progressive and you know
people who make more pay more and but I
will also agree that there is some
profound dysfunction in the system where
very often you end up taking from people
to give them back Oh share of that money
and it just but that's the system the
way it is and this is why I think it
full revamping in my ideal world you
know that would be a priority Stephen
independent from Indianapolis welcome to
the program hello everybody um basically
my comment is the relation of federal
deficit spending is also related to the
de val you the US dollar if the dollar
crashes will lose like twenty five
percent of our standard of living so we
don't believe we need to raise the debt
ceiling otherwise you risk crashing the
dollar there's a direct relation and
that's why the price of gold have gotten
super high and instead of that money
being reinvested back into the economy
that money has been reinvested into gold
and Australians own most of the world's
go in mind most of the world's gold
their economy has benefiting off high
growth thanks Steven explain the impact
on the dollar if you could well I think
anything that that challenges the
strength of the US economy that poses a
risk the US economy such as a potential
default again Vernick and I both agree
that's not going to happen but you know
some people are worried about that if it
did happen it will be catastrophic the
dollar would
almost certainly fall I think one thing
I would just say is this is actually
sort of the area that I've done most of
my research in is actually that up to a
certain point and surprisingly if our
point decline the dollar would actually
be a good thing for the US economy now
if not taken too far so you know a total
crash you know would be another thing
but we've never seen that in a country
that had sound policies obviously the
debt again the debt problem has to be
resolved we must resolve it i mean i can
add just one little thing which is like
I mean I totally agree with you but I
think they will be dramatic consequences
on the dollar also if we don't actually
reform our spending because there is a
moment where investors are going to
understand and perceive us as a very
high risk and and that's a bad thing we
can't continue on this path to the
spending and budget matters a lead
headline in the post yesterday was debt
talks or targeting federal pensions
headline that's drawn a little bit of a
discussion this morning they say that
employees would have to pay more
proposals pose a difficult call for area
lawmakers but to that headline of ironic
dirige a debt talks target federal
pensions is that a good way to go you
know i mean i read that article on the
thing that shocked me the most when I
read it is like they presented it as you
know employees employing the control
increasing their contribution being a
pay cut it's really not a picket when
you are actually contributing to your
your benefits in the future it is i mean
the pension problem i mean when you look
at the financial statement of the united
states federal pension accounts for five
point three trillion dollar of death and
there's unfunded and you know that if we
could actually curious yes the if that
should dinner no for the pension a
federal employees pension and it's a and
and so this these are like big problem
that we have in our future and we need
to address obviously we should have
started 30 years ago
I have I don't want I don't really have
a strong view as to how you know what we
should cut I'm former federal employees
so you know I don't want to take a pay
cut but I don't work for the government
anymore so moving on Beverly New Jersey
Frank Republican good morning to you
yeah good morning you guys always have
the greatest show if you're a more
educational than any other show out
there I have I have a little thing with
mr. the thought there mr. Gagnon you
were talking to a couple of the other
fellows that called in about how you
should tax the people that make more
money okay now there is a large
percentage of the taxpayers in this
country that do not pay taxes okay and I
I don't even consider myself middle
class anymore my wife's hours have been
cut to 30 and I got hill and I'm on I'm
on Medicare and SS state and you're
talking about cutting something that I
Tate into all my life I'm just like that
other fella give me a cash buyout I'll
take the money in our run okay number
two okay you'll never have this in this
country because one party as has
everybody believing that the other party
is going to make everybody die because
they're not going to get health care
they're not going to take care of the
children or the education why don't we
really do this right and have a flat tax
nobody gets a return I don't know what
number you could use but the money just
goes straight into the federal
government's bank and nobody gets a
return and you know what we could
eliminate the IRS that would help cut
the debt to joseph daniel actually i
would support moving eliminating the
income tax if we could collect
everything through essentially sales
taxes and other taxes but but that's
kind of I think farther afield for this
program let me just say on your question
about Medicare again this is a bit a
field but since you raised it I i
totally would be opposed to cutting
Medicare and at least wine the proposals
out there the Ryan proposal essentially
would eliminate Medicare and replace it
with a voucher that people could use to
shop for health care would pay about
seventy percent ultimately of the cost
they had to pay the rest I think that
would be tough for many people to pay up
to thirty percent of their health care
insurance cause I think a better option
would be to find savings we waste about
five percent of GDP that's about one out
of every three health care dollars is
just wasted in duplicate expenses my
doctor for example spends a third of his
day arguing with insurance companies is
pure waste if we can design a better
system that eliminates that waste we can
afford to pay for your Medicare what do
you think of that flat tax idea i mean
i'm in favor of consumption based acts
in general which flat taxes is sort of
so i would agree with this i mean i just
think that we it's an easy talking point
to talk about eliminate eliminating
waste in order to address big-spending
explosion it's never worked it's a very
small part of the explosion in spending
and this is really the problem that we
have is like we have this gigantic
increasing spending and we're going to
have to deal with it and and and of
course the politicians and people we
don't want to feel any pain but some
people will have to feel the pain and
and and obviously it shouldn't be the
people who the program was intended to
serve which are like people who need
that money poor people needy people and
that but it's unrealistic to think that
the system can continue and we can only
you know i will address it by just
getting rid of waste well i guess i
would disagree but with our other guests
their other countries with equal or
better health care outcomes the united
states spend half to two-thirds as much
so it is possible to save money and get
good outcomes we know we know within the
US some companies treat people better
with less money than other companies so
we need to figure out what the good
companies are doing and make the other
companies follow it is possible to
kenneth on the line for Democrats from
alabaster al
hello there Tennessee there yeah I'm
from Opelika Alabama oh go right ahead I
I've been listening to y'all moaning and
when they come up you know a cutting the
VA VIN events and I'm a disabled veteran
from Vietnam and they talked about you
know cutting our pay cut to medicare and
all these people that got wounded or
messed up in Vietnam that that's all I
got to live off of is there check they
getting from the government and they
start talking about cutting you know the
VA benefits Medicare you know I don't
know what's going to happen in this
world I mean I will make enough money
lives you know if they start cutting
them cut their pensions thanks Kenneth
really you know no one is actually
talking about thankfully no one is
talking about cutting benefits for for
people who really needed people were
wounded during Wars who serve this
country no one is talking about cutting
these benefits more importantly actually
one of the case that I'm trying to make
is the fact that because right now we're
overextended and actually you know
high-income people are getting a lot of
subsidies from the government whether
it's in the form of museum free museums
and and a lot of other things like
corporate welfare I mean there's a lot
of resources that we can't actually
focus on the people really truly needed
Kalispell Montana Anthony Republican
good morning Anthony good morning yes
sir well I agree we can't default on our
national debt that would be ridiculous
but look my comment is this everybody
has term limits except Congress in the
Senate you know you hear about senators
with 40 years in the Senate or Congress
why not have a 12 year term limit that
was all some of it and i've never heard
that on the TV yet except for today
another idea term limits there but let's
go back to learning more about the debt
limit Geoghan yawn how do other
countries deal with their debt and debt
limits we know they've been stories out
there whether it's grease or elsewhere
how do what the country's deal with it
well most countries deal with it in the
budget process
and I think it makes a lot of sense
study by the GAO looked at not every
country in the world but quite a few
countries and found only one country
does it the way we do it which is
Denmark where they have a separate debt
ceiling most countries when you pass the
budget and you agreed on a budget it
includes the authorization to borrow as
much as needed to fund that budget which
makes a lot of sense to me and it seems
to me that the whole debt ceiling thing
we're facing now ought to be rolled into
the 2012 budget and then both those
should be solved together and that is
that the argument John Boehner is making
right now to link the two oh stretching
it too far I I haven't heard him make
that Kate I I think I wish he would I
haven't actually heard him say that any
other perspective there I'm i agree but
it would probably be a good idea what I
would want to see is actually spending
and that ceiling talk linked to how much
the government can realistically spend
because right now you tend to have both
of these things totally disconnected so
government make a lot of promises that
sound good about the stuff they're going
to give to people wealthy or poor across
the board without ever having to kind of
put money down on how this is going to
be spent and we have reached a situation
where the real debt ceiling problem is
the fact that we're supposed we're
scheduled to spend three point seven
trillion dollars and only colleague 2.2
trillion and you can blame it on the
recession it is a real problem the
American people knows this is not how it
works in their household when my my
income goes down I cut things even
things i like 15 minutes left with our
guests Macomb Illinois now independent
David what would you like to say or what
would like to learn about the debt
ceiling here no I just like to say this
one thing I have to have a comment about
ah I agree with the guy juggling you
Nick over 80,000 a year you know quite
sure you should be looking more tax than
that be less than that you should be
left access all i have to say thank you
all right and not Washington Kentucky
now it's Helen on the Republican lon
good morning to you I would like for you
gifts to comment on to
how much would we save in interest if as
we lower the debt ceiling that's a easy
way of subtracting we're paying 43 cents
out of every dollar if we lower and down
even their dance forgetting something
Helen hang on a sec we'll get an answer
and they'll come back to your joke and
you can you help us with that interest
on the debt is not 43 cents I'm not sure
where you're getting that numbers for
you yes cents on every dollar is
borrowed and a chunk of that is to pay
interest on the debt but only about five
percent or so so it's not enough to
assault but it is set to explode so for
instance right now we pay one percent of
11 percent of the percentage of GDP is
interest on the debt by the time I
children retire it's going to be forty
percent of the wealth created by
Americans is going to go to pay interest
on our debt of course that world will
never exist because the economy will
implode but you're right if we reduce
our boring interest on our debt will
well go down Helen did you have a second
question yeah as either of them ever
heard the result of President Obama's
press conference that line by line they
were going to go through and eliminate
old prints that line by line they were
going to go through and eliminate old
programs that we waste money on I've
heard nothing of that and i believe it
was two years ago so there should be
over 2,000 plus pages of results from
that back to the budget process well
there's a there's always a big incentive
during campaigns to make promises about
how good and well behaved government
officials are going to be and then when
you're you know when you're actually in
your job it's the infant the incentive
is is much less I mean think about it
this way since the budget laws were
changed in 1974 right it's the first
time ever that Congress did not pass a
budget and by the way last year the
Democrats didn't even have I mean an
excuse and the Republicans are I mean no
better
but I mean because they had the White
House Congress and Congress the Senate
in the house they did not pass the
budget and we're on our way to do the
same thing this year joe canyon yeah I
can't disagree too much with Veronique I
mean I think politicians of both parties
promised more than they can deliver and
it's it's unfortunate what's the effect
on the stock market of all this
discussion right now why don't think
it's been good but I don't see a big
effect I think most financial market
participants don't worry too much about
this they see this is political theater
you know obviously if it goes further
you know I mentioned we mentioned there
are things that Geithner can do to avoid
default but some of those things would
perhaps scare the stock market I think
selling gold might do that it's not to
say it's not better than defaulting but
if this strings out too far it does it
might start to scare the markets let's
go to Fort Bragg North Carolina Felix on
the line for Democrats good morning good
morning c-span in America how are y'all
in this beautiful morning we're doing
great how are you oh if it was any
better I'd have to cut myself 3d I
believe I've got a quick question here
first of all we seem to be having an
argument or debate over the tax and
spend Democrats versus to borrow and
spend Republicans and I have a question
for your guests here what was the actual
debt when obama's budget took over it's
my understanding it was about 1.4
trillion in 2009 the last year bushes
budget took over and think about this
tax and spend type thing it's my
understanding that from 2001 to 2008 the
tax cuts costs about 1.9 tree and as per
the Congressional Budget Office that was
1.7 trillion in taxes given out to the
riches and 200 billion in debt and my
quick question here is this here the we
seem to be willing to cut all these
things here for the poor people what
we're going to have a solid green type
situation whereas all the poor people
just line up and I thought Republicans
were against all these death panels
that's and the American have a great day
he looks left a lot out there
and respond I'll start um well I think
the caller is right I think there's a
confusion maybe between debts and
deficits so but the Congressional Budget
Office did do a study you're right that
said that basically about a third of the
since the year 2000 i think it just in
2001 first year the Bush presidency you
can roughly say that about a third of
the problem the rise in debt is due to
tax cuts about a third is due to more
spending things like the wars in
Afghanistan Iraq and Medicare Part D and
about a third of it is due to the
recession the big recession we just had
which has really walloped tax revenues
so it's about a third a third a third
between tax cuts spending increases and
recession and you could say that but the
truth is that money is fungible right
and the problem is like if you cut spit
if you cut taxes whether it be on anyone
and then you increase spending on social
programs on education on lots of farm
subsidies under the Bush years on roads
on wars on everything sixty percent in
real terms adjusted for inflation sixty
percent increase and you compare this
with like the Clinton years is 12.5
percent by the way increase during eight
years of course you're going to have a
deficit you can't reduce last year
revenue and and dramatically increase
spending Phoenix City yeah yeah go ahead
and finish up my own although I do agree
with what Bernie said I mean we do have
to remember that the country is getting
old nerds people aging that means more
government spending on social security
and medicare is baked into the cake year
after year so so that is something we
have to and we have to deal with that
problem of course but it does it does
rate it makes the pressure to spend more
Charlie's on the line for Republicans
from Phenix City Alabama by hey Charlie
good morning morning oh we talked about
the debt ceiling and everything in the
cost of everything number one why don't
we take whole city state and federal
employees like mr. Gannon old there
young man drawing a check from the
government allowed them
former former employee former wait
doesn't matter i'm sure you get to check
let's allow these people to go out here
retired a certain age and draw their
benefits at the same age that the people
who are on Social Security including
senators and congressmen and I'm sure
they would all agree with it now this is
this is where the real thing is the
benefits and the retirement sees people
get are outrageous hi reaction I mean do
you write actually think there's no
reason why public employees whether it's
in states local governor other federal
government should get any different
treatments but understand that the
reason why this is happening is again
politicians like to make promises
without having to pay for them and this
is one of the one of the one that we
faced with I mean I mean there's a
gigantic pension crisis and states and
and it's going to hurt phenix city
actually we just did Phoenix City Jane
is on the live from Cincinnati now
independent caller hey Jane hi hi my
name is Jane I'm peel from Center not
ancient and I've been listening about
Social Security Medicare Medicaid I
don't exactly that where you're coming
from on that but Medicare we pay for our
Medicare as seniors do and we can't pay
any more than what we're paying if we
could just have our house okay I mean we
worked all of our lives my husband did I
never worked you know I was a
stay-at-home mother and wife and I'm
proud of it I got to see every tooth
come up and my babies had I got to see
her walk and say mommy the first time
everything I didn't have to trust
strangers to watch my baby both me and
my husband decided me not to walk and to
me I I think a lot of people should do
that didn't know where the kids are Jane
from Cincinnati there Howard from
Marietta is it California yes don't
don't you go ahead Howard there's good
morning morning this this young lady is
my hero
she hits it right on the head and the
gentleman there the Democrat we in fact
we just had a conversation where we all
agree that we need to take care of the
veniti the problem is that the gentleman
doesn't agree as to who his needy and
two and two how much is needy and let me
just address the lady from Ohio that has
said she paid into Social Security our
life and the medic help Medicare people
have paid in all their life I agree I
did the same thing okay I worked 40
years I've been retired a number of
years here is the problem with Social
Security and people listen to me social
security was set up as a supplement not
an entire retirement and the problem is
that we have now two people pain in
where when we were paying and it was 14
people and you cannot continue with a
Ponzi scheme the problem is what's the
answer and I wish I wish I had an answer
but I do know the end there is a long
conversation about the debt ceiling
whether it should be raised or not let's
start with Joe Gallo since the caller
reference new face go ahead hey no I
think you put your finger exactly on the
problem which is that as America is
getting to be an older country more
people are retired relative to the
number of workers to support them this
is the big problem and
and I think it's even bigger for health
care than it is for Social Security it
turns out and I don't there is no one
right answer and i'm not here to to to
make a specific proposal but i think
clearly we need to get that on a better
path going forward somehow and i don't i
don't know what the right answer is
great i mean there something that most
people don't understand is like medicare
and medicaid and and and social security
in particular these are not entitlement
Congress can change the law at any time
and here's something that people really
definitely do not understand if we do
not change the system which is becoming
FM starting this year the system will be
running a cash flow deficit for Social
Security and in theory it can cash the
io u--'s that it has an inch respond
until 2036 according to the last a
trustee report that came out on friday
by that time if we have not reform the
system all benefits across the board
will be cut by roughly twenty two
percent and that means that actually we
can we won't be taking care all the
people who truly depend on it the
low-income people I mean we'll see their
benefit cuts it needs to be reformed not
everyone not everyone in America just by
the by the only fact of being 65 an
American should be getting something
from the federal government and we
should focus our resources on the people
can't do without we are down to our last
couple of minutes last couple phone
calls for our guest Lori from Roy Hill
California is on the line for Democrats
hi there moin I wanted going good
morning all i know is that um I'm 50
years old I'm on just I'm on Social
Security and SSI and all I know is I'm
terrified because if they don't raise
the debt then to me it's a matter of
life and death because I can't be
homeless again and a lorry two hundred
dollars out of my ssi
I'm at eight hundred dollars now and um
I guess I just know that I if they don't
raise again if they cut all my money I'm
dad because I can't live without living
to the personal so there's a lot of fear
what a worry in that person's voice so
she really should not worry about this
and one of the reason is is a Treasury
Geithner has the power to decide even we
were to not raise the debt ceiling and
be done with selling our assets and
everything it has the power to
prioritize first pay the interest on a
debt and the principle that is come do n
second pay for Social Security Medicare
Medicaid and these checks will be going
out I mean I so I think you know there
shouldn't be these fears I actually
think this country will come through for
the people really need it first okay no
to the people part of this though
savings benefits the the worry and that
person's was what can you say to the
average person out there well I do I
think it was a very heartfelt Colin and
I i agree with varnish this collar
should not be worried personally but i
think all of us as a country need to
worry I mean this is a serious problem
that must be taught with mary had a
Florida Joe Republican good morning all
right yes sir are you kind of have a
comment that the the public the
constituency always has comments and
questions but we never really hear from
the people who influence the Senate and
the Congress the lobbyists I know that
shows on TV and radio are trying to get
somewhere but it doesn't seem that the
public's ever heard Richmond Texas it's
Richard on the independent line hi
Richard good morning morning question
about the forty-seven percent that do
not pay income taxes I'm not a black
group I pay my taxes or did
and all the other taxes that he talked
about the people we all receive benefits
from the government everybody FBI
Homeland Security the infrastructure
everybody receives those benefits now
why should forty-seven percent of people
not contribute to pay for those benefits
they receive let's hear from our guests
forty-seven percent do not pay the
income tax as as just said you know
everyone pays the sales tax only if you
if you take out the people who do not
pay the payroll taxes it goes down to
fourteen percent but again sales tax is
paid by name everyone the reason why we
have the system the way it is is because
Congress has decided as made a
commitment to actually address and pay
out social benefits through the tax code
that's the reason why we could do it a
different way and have everyone pay and
then said agency you have a budget and
sent out checks this is not the way
Congress has decided richmond richmond
virginia Deborah Republican good morning
yes good morning to all of y'all how
y'all don't I great I just want to say
y'all putting everything that the reason
why everything is so screwed up is
because of the people but y'all have to
look at the accounting if these are
counting agreed it doesn't make any
sense that the government should be out
of money okay to give you an example
okay y'all keep saying people keep
saying we don't panic people or social
security $96 is taken at least not some
people pay more than that for Medicare
every month okay every month okay and
and and it cut off time you can't even
go to your doctor's all year long before
you're cutting before your you reached
your limit the doctors don't get paid
what they supposed to get paid so
where's the money okay uh you need to
look at how much y'all appear for
prescription drugs it doesn't make any
sense thanks final thoughts on the debt
ceiling I mean I just think that you
know we have a real problem we need to
address the
the explosion in spending in Social
Security and Medicare Medicaid going
forward otherwise we will have this
problem repeatedly and we need to
empower I think Americans and let them
keep their money and spend not
everything has to go through the
government well if we agree it's a real
problem and I think Congress need to
deal with it I would like to see this
folded into the budget process and a
long-term solution that we don't need to
raise taxes or cut spending this year or
even next year we have weak economy but
we do need to set in path programs that
were both raised revenue and cut
spending over the long term our guests
have been Joseph Daniel senior fellow at
the Peterson Institute for International
Economics also Veronique de Raji of the
Mercatus Center she's a senior fellow
there at George Mason University thanks
to both of you for your time this
morning